[Applause]
you
Nobel laureates excellencies ladies and
gentlemen it's a great pleasure and
privilege for me to welcome you all to
Karolinska Institutet South America for
the 2017 Nobel lectures in Physiology or
medicine
my name is Ollie Peterson and the rector
vice-chancellor of Carolyn's car
instituted during the Nobel Week and
particularly during the Nobel lectures
we celebrate science and rejoice at the
unique contributions of some truly
exceptional individuals because research
is a way of quenching of a thirst for
knowledge testing around limits and
having an outlet for our creativity and
competitive spirit within Physiology or
medicine the ultimate goal is to achieve
scientific breakthroughs that change our
views of human health disease and normal
vital processes
DLO rates you have surely contributed to
this today it's an honor for me to
extend my warmest welcome on behalf of
Karolinska Institute to Jeff Hall
Michael rosebush and Michael Young the
2017 Nobel laureates in Physiology or
medicine they are receiving the Nobel
Prize for their discoveries on molecular
mechanisms controlling the circadian
rhythm without further ado and I'll call
upon Julian Serrat professor of clinical
integrity physiology and member of the
Nobel Committee for Physiology or
medicine she will introduce the
laureates
clean the floor is yours
[Applause]
your excellencies vice-chair esteemed
laureates dear colleagues ladies and
gentlemen we are now at a high point in
the Nobel Week the Nobel lectures on
behalf of the Nobel assembly that
Karolinska Institutet it is a great
honor for me to introduce the 2017 Nobel
laureates in Physiology or medicine
Jeffery Hall Michael Ross fash and
Michael Young they have received this
year's Nobel Prize in Physiology or
medicine for their discoveries of
molecular mechanisms controlling the
circadian rhythm life on Earth is
adapted to the rotation of our planets
for many years we have known that living
organisms including humans have an
internal biological clock that helps
them anticipate and adapt to the regular
rhythm of the day but how does this
clock actually work Jeff Hall Michael
Ross Bosh and Michael Young were able to
peek inside our biological clock and
elucidate it its inner workings their
discoveries explain help animals and
humans adapt their biological rhythm so
that it's synchronized with the Earth's
rotations using their beloved fruit fly
as a model organism this year's Nobel
laureates isolated a gene that controls
the normal biological rhythm they showed
that this gene encodes a protein that
accumulates in the cell during the night
and then is degraded during the day
subsequently they identified additional
protein components of this machinery
exposing the mechanism governing the
self-sustaining clockwork inside the
cell we now know that nearly all cells
in our body have an inner clock and to
quote one of the laureates Michael Young
we're just all a collection of clocks we
also know that a large proportion of our
genes are regulated by the biological
clock and consequently a careful
calibrated circadian rhythm adapts our
physiology to the different phases of
the day the biological clock regulates
critical functions such as behavior
hormone levels sleep body temperature
and metabolism our well-being is
affected when there's a temporary
mismatch between our external
environment and this internal biological
clock for example when we travel across
several time zones and experience what's
known as jetlag we also know that
chronic misalignment between our
lifestyle and the rhythm dictated by our
inner timekeeper is associated with
increased increased risk for various
diseases since their seminal discoveries
circadian biology has developed into a
vast and highly dynamic research field
as for our health and our well-being
so in addition to this year's Nobel
Prize Jeff Hall Michael Ross Bosch and
Michael Young have been awarded numerous
prizes along their distinguished careers
including the Gruber Prize in
neuroscience the Louisa Gross Horowitz
prize the Shaw prize the Wiley Prize in
biomedical sciences and the Gardner
foundation international award as they
say in the field of chrono biology it is
time to hear from each of the laureates
and I'm the timekeeper for this
afternoon's session we'll hear three
individual lectures and this really is a
unique opportunity for us to gain
first-hand insight into their journeys
and these journeys that have led to
their seminal discoveries of mechanisms
controlling the circadian rhythm these
journeys have likely been fueled by
scientific inquiry little mischief hard
work teamwork
maybe a little friendly competition and
of course one cannot forget their love
of genetics and that of the fruit fly so
now I'll begin with the introduction of
the first of our three laureates and
this is professor emeritus Jeffrey hall
he's a geneticist in a chronal biologist
and he is a professor emeritus of
biology at Brandeis University professor
Hall received his doctorate degree in
1971 at the University of Washington in
Seattle he was a postdoc with Seymour
Benzer who was a pioneer in the field of
genetics and he performed this postdoc
at the California Institute of
Technology
he joined the faculty at Brandeis
University in 1974 and in 2002 he became
associated with the University of Maine
he was elected into the yule Academy of
Sciences for his revolutionary work in
the field of chrono biology professor
Hall has spent his career examining the
neurological components of fly courtship
and behavioral rhythms now I'd like to
ask you all to join me in welcoming this
year's Nobel laureate professor Jeff
Hall up to the stage and we will hear a
lecture from him entitled the little
flies multifaceted basic research coming
out better than intended professor Hall
[Applause]
do I just start talking you just start
talking okay so as Willy Loman would say
isn't this a remarkable thing that
alludes to the fact that I'm extremely
grateful and deeply honored for all of
what's going on here and this week
beyond this week whether or not the
whole deal makes my mind boggle at the
thought mind but this leads me to segue
into some claims that I'm gonna make
some additional remarks having to do
with gratitude in in certain general
crypto historical ways about various
predecessors that ended up being at
least loosely connected with the
research in question and further words
of gratitude to certain specific
biologists and geneticists so for
example not too long after I was
attempting to establish research at
Durrell BrandX University in North East
us as a pleasant surprise to me I was
invited to give a presentation at the
National Drosophila meetings this had
been kick-started by my second mentor in
my time in the late 1950s estimable
geneticist named Larry Sandler rest in
peace and many years later I was invited
to speak at the Drosophila meeting in
the late 1970s or so by which time
meeting had grown to be a at least
numerically more significant and I was
wondering why did I receive such an
invitation I knew why because another
mentor of mine Dan Linsley a close
colleague of Sandler invited me as a
favor he was one of the meeting
organizers so I had just started
attempting to establish a research
enterprise studying at the time as you
heard brief mention fruit fly courtship
behavior studied potentially study about
genetically and therefore having the
potential further to dig into the neural
substrates of this kind of fruit fly
behavior so I was trying to fill out
thirty minutes or so with something
rather about our first blush studies of
courtship anything that much to say so a
key part of this presentation had to do
with a infamous courtship reproductive
behavioural mutant Buffalo which have
been rattling around the fly world for
several years and nobody was actually
studying it of friends for good reason
but it did lead to the creation of
certain underground movies that showed a
group of this genetic variant type in a
wild frenzy of courtship like
interactions between and among the flies
in this filthy film so one of the
members of the audience at this for safa
meeting sitting near the front quipped
this is like I am curious yellow forked
that's a joke not a funny joke but it
has the benefit of referring to one of
my favorite movies they came out of this
country
you as I'm curious blue and the final
the final feature of this clip the
English words yellow in forked makes an
overt reference to a certain type of
genetic in Drosophila of the chromosomal
type many genetic variants over the
years harking back to more than one
hundred years ago were above the level
of genic changes instead chromosomal
level changes anomalies with the
designator that included ice again
yellow forked okay so those movies meant
a whole hell of a lot to me certainly
more than various bear mountain eras
which included things like the
protagonist played checkers with death
or something I didn't understand any of
that
but the the fellow who made this
tasteless jape from the audience was
somebody who in principle should be
known about by many in this room
including those involved in the prize
awardee organization because the fellow
who said this who often behaved like it
was as a dirty dirty man was Edward
Louis who received this prize in the mid
1990s for his work that included a heavy
dose of Drosophila genetics and Edie
Edie Lewis was a student back when he
was a baby he was a student of one of
the Giants in genetic history one Alfred
Sturtevant Sturdivant was the academic
offspring of Thomas Hunt Morgan who was
the first row Sophos to be awarded this
prize in the 1930s and Morgan generated
a variety of academic
of offspring notably a famed trio of
what you might call Morgan's f1 that
included Sturdivant and another member
of this trio was a another at the time
fledgling Drosophila geneticist named
Hermann Muller now Muller based on a
discovery he made at the University of
Texas in the middle south of the United
States in a ASUS of intellectual
activity within that state we're by the
way Mike Young whom you of course hear
from today Mike Young did his PhD thesis
work at the University of Texas
so Muller did work then which was seemed
to be very salient at the time at least
and that led to Muller being awarded
this prize in the 1940s for Muller to
accomplish what he did for his
prize-winning study it was
quintessential
for him to have designed and generated a
particular kind of Drosophila
chromosomal variant which made all the
difference for the performance of that
study this is a category of chromosomal
variant which I won't burden you with
detail wise which became one of the
great secret weapons of Joseph Oliver's
research over many many subsequent
decades without which a huge number of
Drosophila could have never done
anything if it hadn't been for this type
of chromosomal a base variant now back
to the matter of another type of
chromosomal variant that I've already
referred to that includes the
designators yellow in Fort Muller
it was Muller himself who generated that
now classic type of chromosomal variant
in the 1940s although it did not he
didn't get the Nobel Prize for that
it was for other features of his and
genetically-based studies but these
chromosomal variants which were often
designed deliberately and constructed
via the usual cytogenetic mumbo-jumbo
works powerfully applicable to ask and
answer some genetic questions what I
call genetic genetics about hereditary
factors but the variants were maintained
survived down the generations the
fruit-fly generations and the human ones
and several of them turned out to be
massively applicable for other reasons
later on ok now the back to ed ed Louis
and the irrespective of what he said
from the front row during that fruitful
egg meeting when I was rambling on about
courtship behavior that in here I need
to mention another of the third member
of Thomas on Morgan's famous trio is f1
this is Calvin Blackmon bridges who made
massive contributions in genetic history
including establishing major elements of
what is known as fruit Flight
cytogenetics observing and analyzing
chromosomes including the chromosomes
contained in these aforementioned types
of genetic variants when my first mentor
in my time as an undergraduate yes it
was during the 30 Years War my first
mentor was his name was named Russ and
peace Phillip Ives and he was
supervising a small coterie of
undergraduates and we were doing meager
little fruit fly genetics projects and
he was a superb instructor massively
enthusiastic motivational he really
taught us a whole hell of a lot of what
to do with a given would be researched
day but also he imbued his charges with
what I realized later was described by
the phrase the lore of Drosophila the
deep background of research initially
genetic genetics involving this organism
which goes back more than a hundred
years from now and Ives like it Louis
Ives was a student working under
Sturdivant in the southwestern US and
what some would call I never would call
the dumb blonde of the United States
near L near la but in any event one of
Ives and Lewis's lab mates was bridges
when Morgan moved from New York City
northeastern us to the Los Angeles area
he brought in it was in the late 1920s
he brought with him Sturdivant and
bridges Muller as he grumbled about for
the rest of his life was exiled to
places like Texas and Russia but anyway
Ives told me when I was beginning to get
a little bit of a feel about what fruit
fly genetics can ask an answer
potentially ives mentioned that bridges
who was his academic uncle if you will
bridges had the best I to notice novel
sports you could say variants at the
anatomical level he had the best eye to
detect these as he and his lab mates
would plow through these enormous mounds
of fruit flies under the microscope
searching for rare novel anatomical
changes and one of those that bridges
found back in New York in the nineteen
teens was immediately as all the other
sports immediately rolled into there
netic processes where they asked does
this anatomical change have a genetic
causation and might it be hard
specifiable that way and many of these
variants have that attribute and so
based on formal genetics they started to
create lots of information about the
nature of this insects genome with
regard to genetic variants including
genic variants in addition to
chromosomal level variants but this
particular genetic variant that bridges
which is quite subtle that bridge is
detected in 1916 seems as if it might be
also biologically interesting
potentially as opposed to just a an
extra genetic tool in the genetic
variant toolkit biologically interesting
compared for instance with some of these
variants that had for instance altered
eye color snore not necessary that
interesting biologically so Louis
working under Sturdivant with bridges as
his lab mate and with eyes as another
lab mate who divulged to me part of the
lore of Drosophila about what a great
eye bridges himself had to notice novel
variants Lewis began his career after
his PhD research studying purely genetic
genetic phenomena in Drosophila but a
while later Lewis made a lateral move
just as a duck might make a lateral move
all along I call part of my internal
argot biogenetics and he picked up on
bridges variant the one which seemed to
bridges and other of his lab mates to be
interesting potentially at the
biological level more than just genetics
itself and Lewis for several decades
subsequently pounded away at the factors
pointed to by that bridges
Varian and many additional related
genetic variants related genetically and
biologically and initiated the majority
of his Louis's career in studying the
animals development by taking a genetic
approach when I was fortunate to get to
know II D well and realize that he was a
developmental geneticist par excellence
and a funky little fellow as well
cute-as-a-button by the way Louis was at
Caltech toiling in absolute obscurity
even within that department B he was
ignored or disparaged in the main he was
kind of a recluse his members of his lab
I think was one other person and but
those who knew of them since said on his
behalf
well it doesn't publish anything this is
now the early 70s he had not published a
paper since the mid-50s
they said he doesn't do that because
he's a perfectionist he demands yes and
perfection before he puts pencil to
paper and this got back to Ed naturally
and he once said to me in private he
said Jeff this is caca he said I'm not
publishing anything because I haven't
found anything in living memory and that
was reality but a few years later in the
late 70s Ed burst forth with a
publication late 70s that won him the
Nobel Prize and this and this was all
based on the genetic variant at at root
found by bridges back in the 1980s
so this variant and many associated
variants including chromosomal
aberrations mind you other categories
seem to say a whole hell of a lot about
how certain genes help construct this
organism beginning at the earliest stage
of development this paper 78 also had
strong evolutionary implications
even in the pre molecular era the
relevant genetic factors in Drosophila
or else or had not yet been identified
DNA wise okay so an example of how you
can muddle along and admit to yourself
that you're not getting anywhere but you
you hope that you're making a tad of
progress during a given half decade keep
going and something might will out as it
did in the case of edy which is you know
thanks in part to his wherewithal going
back to morgan sturdivant with a lot of
ancillary help from Muller and naturally
bridges that that this whole project
that Ed was mired in when I first got to
know him was an example of something
coming up better that he intended or at
least expected but as you also heard a
mention of in the introductory remarks
another corner of the overall biogenetic
enterprise in principle a priori might
involve Drosophila behavior as opposed
to developments starting with a
fertilized a most conspicuously
postnatal behavior after you get the
mature adult animal and so by a behavior
biogenetics was pioneered principally
conspicuously by the aforementioned
Seymour Benzer who by then had moved to
Caltech and took advantage of Ed Lewis's
local genetic and from the Somaly base
genetic expertise so Benzer instead of
just imagining he might encounter the
occasional behavioral variant made a
systematic attempt to generate
behavioral variants from scratch and
systematically search for them the way
he did this the only way it would have
worked was to apply you guessed it the
aforementioned
vivid EBU yellow fork
chromosomal variant which made all the
difference for this mutant hunt to work
and it did work and several of these
first blush behavioural mutants ended up
pointing to
well definable genes with interesting
products interesting products that
function on behalf of the animals post
natal activities behavior physiology in
her chemistry as the case may be but
aping the Benzer approach one year later
this is methylase a student inventors
lab Ronald J Konopka said I'm gonna do
the same thing the self st. genetic
tactic applying did I did at that yellow
fork once again very powerfully
applicable as came to be realized
decades after Muller generated it he
said I'm gonna search for novel variants
but in this case of a particular type
daily rhythm variants that would show
abnormalities or anomalies of daily
biological rhythms in Drosophila and
what Konopka did therefore was kick
start perhaps unwittingly
then a tiny sub cottage industry
enterprise he kick-started what is now
in this century has become industrial
level research in chrono genetics and
molecular genetic chronobiology
including neurobiology the Konopka
was a rare bird and very adept at what
he was doing both in terms of chrono
biology and genetics thanks to being
mentored as ron was by lewis largely but
he wasn't absolutely alone even though
toronto genetics was a tiny tiny subset
of the biogenetic enterprise because
shortly after Konopka
initiated the whole deal some fungal
geneticists did the same kind of thing
they searched for rhythm variants in a
species of fung
which should be appreciated by many in
this room because working on this fungal
species Nawroz pura led to one of the
banner Nobel prizes in the history of
the whole deal
when George beetle and Edward Tatum
realized that Norris pure genetics is
aces but they weren't studying genetic
phenomena alone they were using neurons
for genetics to ask questions about not
just what is a gene if you know what a
gene is sitting there somewhere that's
not enough what is a gene doing what's
coming out of a gene and Beadle and
Tatum made major contributions to what
later became known as gene action and
which later on was often as a kind of a
aphorism DNA makes RNA makes protein
okay but in a Ross Perot at least in
part because you can do fine genetics
with that species of fungus became also
a chrono genetic system in that fungus
after Konopka had initiated the fruit
fly side of things
Norris for okra know genetics I found in
my opinion which is infallible is aces
but at a minimum I was very glad and
very appreciative of becoming acquainted
with the neuro so a fungal folk who were
studying rhythms because at the early
rhythm conferences I went to and you
could never imagine the falter all at
these conferences coming from the
lecterns in the front of the room it was
bigger the imagination and I would be
sitting next to the Norris bro chrono
geneticists in question J Dunlop and
Jennifer Loras and we would be sitting
there rolling our eyes heavenward at
what was coming out of a given speaker
and J or Jennifer would lean sideways
and say yeah you're right forget about
that that is authentic chrono gibberish
but every once in a while they lean
sideways and say that's
registering and processing later at the
bar so it rhythms rhythm research in
part when you get clear with various of
the phenomena and the norms and the
jargon and so forth rhythms are
interesting I claimed lots of research
is can be comes under the heading of
dryest dusts often study by professor
dry as dust but rhythms are interesting
in part because they're accessible to
researchers it's thing it just seems
neat that biological cells and tissues
can harbor clocks biological clocks not
electromechanical biological what could
they be and back when I and Mike Ross
fish Michael Ross Fisher Mike Young got
into this nobody had a clue what a clock
could be composed over how it might
operate but we imagined we imagined that
taking a genetic and eventually
molecular genetic approach the latter
being quintessential that we might
contribute to understanding how rhythms
are established and regulated and how do
they clunk along every day all day
what am I out of time already I'm out of
my mind which that's not possible there
is no mind left but anyway this brings
me to another claim which is cavalier
and whimsical is that I think I believe
that this year with regard to this Prize
in Physiology or medicine oddly named
that there should be five awardees there
should be five awardees this year in
this category and one of them should be
the little flies which have contributed
also there can't be five awardees that
flouts the rules or as Americans would
say
flaunts the roles they most of them
being illiterate but but a worthy number
for should be the little flies because
as exemplified they've created massive
amounts of biological in addition to
genetic knowledge going back more than a
hundred years of time and the fifth
awardee silly as this may sound should
be the phenomenon rhythmicity because
rhythms are are arguably interesting and
you've already heard about why they
should be regarded as interesting and
you're going to hear much more about
that in meaningful words and pictures
from professors raw special young but
rhythms are interesting and and as
you'll be hearing about they're
ubiquitous among organisms and even
within a given type of organism their
universal attributes descriptively seems
to point to how important they must be
and as if they may have in fact than one
of the earliest things that evolved as
americans would say six thousand years
ago one life arose here on the third
Rock from the Sun but to study for
mutants with abnormal rhythms in fruit
flies and then the rostra and later
variety of other organisms that those
mutations where I had interesting
abnormalities but the mutations causing
the mutant rhythm anomalies the
mutations also pointed to genes and as
Michael had said even in in private and
even in mixed company Jewish and Gentile
that for this biogenetic enterprise
chrono genetics it was quintessential
you could never meaningfully predict
what these genes would be about what
kinds of products would come
of them unless the jeans and the
products were identified empirically by
actual lab work so the molecular side of
the chrono genetic Enterprise which
essentially needed to become and did do
molecular T as well so the final things
I'll say here having given a tip of the
hat or so2 varies predecessors including
my two mentors and their associates who
I wished I were alive when bridges
Sturdevant and even Muller who I never
met I begged my mentors to introduce me
and they refused but many of my
predecessors that I did or did not have
anything to do with personally no hell
of a lot to me but springing forward
into the 1980s and beyond
I think it's worth mentioning that
they're actually of course can only be
three awardees in this category this
year as every year three or fewer but
and the three or T's or what in terms of
American research grant jargon RPI's the
3p is that stands for principal
investigator
perhaps the adjutant is correct although
not all P is actually investigate as
you've been but I part of my own
internal lingo was to refer to lab mates
such as in the lab of what I nominally
supervised and Michael did and Mike did
and those who still do or ai's actual
investigators and I I can't help give a
tip of the hat to a subset of these
those who voted with their feet in their
pocketbooks to travel long distances to
be part of this peak of double D boo
such as people I can never forget and
never failed to appreciate chrono wise
at least like Dan does carry aku and
Cathy
Sawicki and Ralston Eskie and Joe Levine
some of the major contributors to the
chrono genetic molecular neuro
and then and then when Michael Ross Besh
and I went half of each of her live
joined forces one of the great joys
believe it or not even I'm a terrible
sourpuss but I really genuinely joy
coming to what I laughingly called work
because I realized that there were all
these fine ai's nominally under me but
also in Michaels lab people I I know
that some of them have made this trip
for this week
like Paul Hardin and Ravi alotta but
there was a really a doubling or more
than a doubling of a eyes with whom to
interact and a is in the two labs got to
do both in terms of vocational and
personal matters to have a large by lab
research group everybody studying in
various different ways an arguably
interesting phenomenon very study of all
in the the little flies and then later
and I'll never forget this and I'll
never fail to appreciate what she did
this is now vaunted professor Leslie
vassal who was when I first met her with
in the early 90s was a baby
working Michael so Mike Young's lab in
New York City and at some dumb meeting
which are always done scientific but the
one thing I remember from that meeting
at the Leslie Vose all single-handedly
kick-started a situation were the three
labs the three chrono genetic molecular
chrono were beginning to communicate and
this made the whole deal better
professionally and personally to get to
know a is in Mike's life such as
professor now professor voss hall and
Amita Sehgal who is here who traveled a
long way and several other AIS there are
many many other eyes among the three
labs away Evan mentioned
because they didn't travel to Stockholm
or I am unaware that they did or didn't
but it was just I mean you know your
your supervisees make all the difference
in terms if anything is going to happen
and it's often just on a day to day
basis interesting and enjoyable to
interact with them even if the pie is
not really supervising it's like you
know Michael and I in one office of the
other sitting down and talking about
sports outcomes Agony's or something but
nonetheless the a is between two lads
and then with a third lab from the same
region of the United States but far away
it really began but three lab group in
terms of communication and even palpable
cooperation so the whole thing was and I
think it did come out better than we
intended at least at the beginning going
back to the late 70s but however it was
going to come out it was just it was
really almost sensually enjoyable to
deal with the little flies and all the
potential that they create including
genetics and then molecular and genomics
and they behaved in a very complex
sophisticated way more sophisticated
than the behavior of many humans which
is like shooting fish in a barrel but
but they they divulge it's almost like
in some mystical stupid way that you
said my God if you seriously and if you
know what you're doing and you care I'm
gonna give up a secret or two if you
just keep going even if for a while if
nobody's necessarily paying any
attention as in the case of the vaunted
Edie Lewis rest in peace who was as
self-admittedly he was always very
different fellow was totally obscure
even within his own department until he
burst forth with studies which had
spectacular heuristic value to
understand not only Drosophila
development but developmental phenomena
underpinned by genetic factors in all
kinds of other animals Michael's just
waggly something at me is it it wasn't
quite an obscene gesture but it should
have been um but the same happened again
better than we intended that these fruit
fly chrono factors genic mutants
mutations molecular clones connected
with analogous and even literally
homologous factors way beyond the insect
arena which I don't think we would have
never particularly anticipated back in
the late 70s but Jesus to work on the
little flies and to be mentored in part
about the lore of Drosophila which
didn't really help it was just
interesting and it's kind of
motivational so the tip of my hat to all
these predecessors all these successors
and especially you know someday come on
guys give a prize to an invertebrate
it'll be it'll be funky but warranted so
I'm done well I'm really done in in life
as well as but if there's been any
attention I thank you for it
[Applause]
and so now we move forward the clock
ticks Michael Ross Bosch is the Peter
Gruber professor of Neuroscience at
Brandeis University an investigator at
the Howard Hughes Medical Institute he's
a geneticist molecular biologist and a
chrono biologist he received his
doctoral degree in 1970 at the
Massachusetts Institute of Technology in
Cambridge under Sheldon Penman
subsequently he spent three years on a
postdoctoral fellowship in genetics at
the universe since 1974 he's been on the
faculty at Brandeis University at
Waltham where he's collaborated as you
heard with Jeffery Hall and investigated
the genetic influences on circadian
rhythms of the internal biological clock
Michael Ross Bosch is a member of the US
National Academy of Sciences in more
recent years he has been working on the
brain neuronal aspects of circadian
rhythms I would like to ask you all to
join me in welcoming professor Ross
Bosch to the stage where he will deliver
his 2017 Nobel Prize lecture entitled
the circadian clock transcript a
transcriptional feedback and the
regulation of gene expression welcome
[Applause]
so it's a great pleasure to be here a
great honor I
this this whole business since the 2nd
of October at 5:00 10:00 in the morning
Boston time has left me
virtually speechless but being
speechless is not really appropriate
here is it so I'm afraid I'm gonna have
to screw up my courage and try and say
something so let me begin by trying to
give you a little introduction to
circadian rhythms and first as I like to
do to not forget this I want to thank my
current lab for the work they're
currently doing which I'll try and
allude to at the end if I have a moment
pay attention to the time here and
especially kata Brut see who's been with
me for 16 years and has made the trip
here to Stockholm to celebrate with all
of us and so circadian rhythms is a
biochemical as as the slide says
physiological and behavioral adaptation
to the rotation of the earth and there
are two purposes to this one is
anticipation namely the early bird gets
the worm and the early worm avoids being
eaten by the bird and secondly the clock
manages to to create internal coherence
so the different reactions different
steps in metabolism for example happen
in order and not all simultaneously
oxidative reduction reactions are
happiest when they're separated in time
and so circadian rhythms arose a long
time ago in response of course to this
rotation of the earth and the rotation
of the
earth was occurring well before
nutrition anything was anything like
what's currently available on our planet
and well before the atmosphere had its
current gaseous constitution and in fact
the oldest clock we know the clock in
cyanobacteria really participated in
oxygenation of the atmosphere so 2
billion years ago we lived in a we lived
the planet experienced a reducing
atmosphere and it was really
cyanobacteria with the aid of its clock
that produced the oxygen that enabled
life as we currently know it to arise
and so clocks exist really in different
kingdoms not only in bacteria as I just
alluded to but also in plants and in
animals which I will focus on and it's
likely that these clocks arose
independently because there's very
little evidence of a relationship
especially between the cyanobacterial
clock and animal clocks and probably
even the plant clocks arose
independently so this is such a powerful
such a powerful contribution to fitness
that it arose in these independent lines
and so a simple systems view of
circadian clocks a so-called Skinner
Graham named after Arnold Eskin one of
the early pioneers in the field is
illustrated here and and it simply
demonstrates the fact that there are
input signals principally light also
temperature which entrain the clock the
clock does not run exactly at 24 hours
our endogenous period in humans for
example is about 12 to 15 minutes long
and it's light every day which resets
our clock back to 24 hours
those are the input signals and then
there are outputs all kinds of things
that we measure we commonly measure so
called the hands of the clock which of
course are not the clock itself the
clock of the gears inside and the hands
simply respond at various points to the
to the clock itself and and it's really
the the nature of the pacemaker the
nature of the timekeeper which is the
focus of this lecture in fact the focus
of this prize and as as as Jeff alluded
to at the beginning of this problem
certainly the beginning for us not the
beginning of all circadian work but the
modern beginning is really due to
Konopka and bends are shown here on the
bottom right not at the beginning when
ron was a student in his lab but much
later in an interview and and these two
people and it was really Konopka who
brought the circadian problem to Seymour
Konopka was interested as an
undergraduate in circadian rhythms and
he suggested as Jeff indicated why don't
we apply this genetic expertise to this
biological problem in drosophila and
they isolated three alleles of this gene
they named period
and and those three alleles either
eliminated rhythms altogether they gave
there was a short period variant and a
long period variance the so-called /
zero allele / s for short and / L for
long and remarkably these alleles these
variants had exactly the same effect on
two completely different rhythmic
phenomena namely emergence of the adult
from the pupil case shown on your left
or local motor activity rhythms the
running around of the fruit fly the
fruit flies activity rest cycle now we
know they're sleep-wake cycle which were
which were either absent short or long
exactly as as one might have anticipated
from the from the eclosion from the
eclosion rhythms so this was a
magnificent contribution and for those
of you who chase high-profile papers and
perhaps this is a different angle on
chef's ed Lewis story
in the first decade after this paper was
published it had ten citations so so you
you you the the the high profile papers
are not necessarily the ones which have
staying power and so in it at Brandeis
Jeff and my lab got together and
independently Mike Young's lab in
Rockefeller to clone this gene in the
early days of recombinant DNA and this
is a picture of the group that that did
this wills airing Tony James the guy in
the middle is for Nita ready that's me
believe it or not and and Dave wheeler
and so he was that group and and in fact
an additional group of people in my lab
who I'm gonna focus on there were also
people in Jeff's lab but I want to sort
of make sure that I acknowledge the
people in my lab who contributed to this
pronita already mentioned Chang you shin
Lo and yo f city who unfortunately
passed away and and that group really
contributed to cloning and sequencing
the period gene in my lab in the early
mid mid 80s and the the outcome was that
this was a pioneer protein that meant
this was such early days that the
sequence identified no relatives in the
database seek the number of sequence
proteins was so small that the chance of
hitting upon
relative a gene with a similar sequence
which might give you a clue as to what
the protein was doing just didn't exist
and so we spent several years struggling
to try to exit mmm
find the promised land from the desert
and and one clue for us was a paper that
Changyu produced in 1987 that that
suggested that an intriguing repeat
region within the protein which turns
out to be not very interesting anymore
was not necessary for circadian function
in other words we could take the DNA
that encoded the period protein
transform it into an arrhythmic animal
and we got perfectly good circadian
function which was missing this
particular region so that suggested that
we needed to look in a different
direction and as science often has it it
turned out that the literature started
to provide a bit of a clue for a
direction to look at and this paper was
produced
shortly after Chang's paper from Steve
Cruz and Cory Goodman and they cloned a
Drosophila gene called single-minded and
it was a nuclear protein they actually
didn't know at the time it was a
transcription factor just a nuclear
protein and and it had homology to the
period protein in fact we were now no
longer the Pioneer single-minded was the
new protein and they they were they
benefited from having us there although
of course we didn't know what our
protein did it was it was of limited
utility except providing a high profile
connection for their paper and so
nonetheless the nuclear localization of
single-minded suggested to us that gene
expression in some way might be relevant
to the function of the period protein
and shortly thereafter Paul Hardin who
was a postdoc in my lab really produced
what is arguably
the most important paper from my lab
that the period gene product the protein
was involved in a feedback loop which
affected which regulated the
oscillations of its own mRNA and and
this is a quantitation of those data and
and the key thing there are Q key
features of this one is that the
messenger RNA profile goes like this in
time and there are 24 hours between
Peaks but if that experiment is done in
the per short background in which the
period protein has a one amino acid
difference from the wild-type protein
then the distance between those Peaks is
19 or 20 hours rather than 24 hours
exactly mimicking the behavior and so we
proposed that that this must be really
important
perhaps central to timekeeping but as
I'll try and explain in just a couple of
minutes it was still a little bit of
work to come up with a more a tighter
more more restricted model and this is a
present that Paul gave me less than a
month ago at a party we had and this is
the original gel showing oscillations
and and and the original paper under
glass reversing you know it was it was a
present that was framed and so so I
cherish this gift thank you Paul
and and this was really not easy to do
for two reasons one is when you use
whole flies there were no oscillations
that were visible you had to use heads
that was his brainchild because in the
body there's lots of tissues which don't
undergo oscillation and that damped the
signal so it really wasn't visible it's
often in science a very small change
which makes all the difference and and
and secondly this is before PCR so these
these assays were done by RNAs
protection and that itself is a little
bit of a story which I'll come to
so this particular gel gave rise to a
model and and I call it a cautious model
this is the actual picture from the
paper the last figure of the paper and
and what I want you to appreciate was
that there was no mention of
transcription in the title or the
abstract in other words feedback loop it
was there was feedback loop but no
mention of transcription and the way we
imagined this was that it could work at
the post transcriptional level for
example maybe messenger RNA half-life
was affected was regulated and not
transcription it could be transcription
and moreover it could be indirect in
other words the period protein could
affect these things directly but perhaps
the period protein affects another
protein which is actually the direct
regulator or a most indirect if you will
is that the period protein could
influence behavior which could in fact
feed back and affect the molecular
oscillations in other words behavior
would actually be upstream as opposed to
downstream of the molecular oscillations
so we were very conservative about this
and and it turned out that over the next
two or three years that there were three
paid for papers that my lab produced the
first of which was really also Paul's
work which cemented the feedback loop
model and emphasized transcription so
this first paper in PNAS and and in
interesting and interesting aside is we
really had trouble publishing this paper
because everyone assumed this was
transcription and I my lab worked on
post transcriptional regulation in yeast
half of my lab and so I was well aware
that this was not a slam-dunk this was
not for sure to be transcriptional and
and what this paper showed was the fact
that the pre messenger RNA the intron
containing RNA also underwent circadian
oscillations the sense
indistinguishably from the messenger RNA
and also you could take the upstream
region the promoter region of the gene
and you could put it in front of a
reporter gene in this case choline
acetyltransferases cat and and and and
that regulatory dammit
that regulatory DNA would would would
oscillate that that that reporter RNA
would oscillate in exactly the same way
as the purr RNA so all you needed was
the upstream DNA really indicating that
this was very likely to be transcription
so the models strongly favored
transcription and then over the next
couple of years
three more papers really cemented this
model one hour only collaboration with
the aforementioned Seymour Benzer in
which immuno electron microscopy was
done to show that the period protein was
really nuclear if we constitutively
overexpressed the protein this work done
by Hongzhang honk we zhang who was an
eminent neuroscientist today the
scientific director of the L Institute
then then this would clamp period mRNA
levels very low and and non oscillating
consistent with a repressor function and
and lastly the the region of homology
between
single minded and period and then a
third protein then so-called named the
past domain turned out to be a
dimerization domain which could account
for the how period would work as a
repressor namely by associating with a
positive transcription factor which
contained a past domain in this this
study was led by josh wong who is and
that also an eminent neuroscientist at
Cold Spring Harbor today so that really
led us to the negative feedback loop
model at the level of transcription and
I should say at this time or shortly
before this time I won a bet from Mike
Young dinner
for the four of us their wives that gene
expression would be the focus of the
function of the protein and he paid his
debts and we had a lovely dinner and so
he mammals entered the story at this
time when Joe Takahashi and his
colleagues initiated and carried out a
really heroic genetic screen in mice in
some ways encompassing the original
Konopka and Benza work plus the cloning
the seek and the rat and the rescuing
and the sequencing of the protein and
came up with a mutant which affected
circadian rhythms very dramatically
fortunately for them fifth Mouse which
was several standard deviations off the
norm for the period that they would
normally see here's the wild-type
phenotype and here's the that particular
mutant Mouse and and of course they
named they named that Mouse they named
that gene clock and it turned out to be
a past containing transcription factor
which plays a role in this story and at
the same time in my lab Ravi alotta
who's here and jean rutila were involved
in a lengthy genetic screen to try to
find other circadian mutants and we we
knew about the the remarkable work in
the young lab and we didn't want to
duplicate what they were doing looking
for period altered mutations so we
actually looked at a rhythmic mutations
and and it turns out that a rhythmic
mutations are very easy to find we had
more than 40 of them but they're very
hard to sort out to distinguish
interesting ones from uninteresting ones
and so we devised a sub screen and the
sub screen for these mutants was to look
at which
of the strains had non-cycling in very
low period and timeless levels the idea
being that if we had hit upon the
positive transcription factor we were
looking for the X in in our diagram then
then there should be no cycling and and
low levels and in fact we only found
three three mutant strains which met
that criterion and two of those turned
out to be alleles of cycle or B mal the
ortholog and mammals and one of them
turned out to be an allele of clock so
in fact we we had closed the circle if
you like and and managed to identify the
positive transcription factor the
heterodimer that drives period and
timeless which then represses clock and
cycle and it turns out three of the same
four proteins function in the same way
in the same way in in mammals and so
this is really conserved in the five
hundred fifty million years or so of
evolution since flies and mammals
diverged clearly present in the common
ancestor that lived long ago and of
course i'm focusing on transcriptional
regulation but there's a whole world of
post transcriptional regulation that
mike mike will allude to for example the
function of timeless and double time
genes that were isolated in his lab so
this is now a common theme as you've
already heard among circadian
oscillators Neurospora plants mice where
an activator leas gives rise to the
synthesis of a repressor which then
increases in concentration and then that
repressor feeds back in the nucleus
interacts with the activator turns off
synthesis of the repressor of the
proteins the messenger RNAs and proteins
decay away and the whole system starts
again then
so I just mentioned very briefly
something contemporary just to show that
this particular aspect of investigation
is not over this is a chip seek profile
for the active scientists who might be
interested in the audience this is a
sixth time time nighttime course from
the morning and then throughout the day
to the evening and this is the
association of timeless or period with
the upstream region of the DNA with
these so-called a boxes this is when the
repressors associate and the black
arrows indicate the time at which clock
or the positive factor associates with
these same regions and of course not
surprisingly there's a delay between the
association of the activator and the
subsequent Association of the repressors
so the repressors build up and then
associate to turn off transcription and
it turns out to be to be quite
interesting that the profile if one does
exactly the same kind of assay but in
this case actually tries to identify the
proteins by mass spectrometry that are
associated with the clock sight complex
on chromatin that there's a much more
discreet Association of period and
timeless at the time of maximum
repression in other words the by chip
seek the proteins associate continuously
whereas by mass spec there's a much more
great feature of association and so
there's something that's very different
that happens at a very particular time
on chromatin that's associated with this
repression step and this is only to say
a word about this particular kind of
particular kind of assay and so beyond
the feedback loop I just will say a word
about the fact that we and others we and
others have have tried to address the
notion of how much oscillation is there
really and in a paper that we published
in 2001 we made two findings one is that
there are a large number of cycling
rnase in fly heads much beyond this very
constrained small feedback loop and
secondly that oscillation none of these
cycling's RNAs happen without a
functional clock psych complex so in
other words the small feedback loop
really does sit at the top of a
hierarchy which gives rise to a large
number of oscillating transcripts and of
course the current view the way to put
this together and create a cartoon to
rationalize this if you like is the fact
that this small feedback loop here which
governs timing there are a few more as a
small or perhaps nots a small number of
direct target genes those direct target
genes include other transcription
factors and those other transcription
factors lead to the the oscillation of
secondary secondary target genes and and
output functions and it's really this
this idea coupled with the fact that
there are in in mammals flies as well
there really are clocks in all tissues
of the body
not only the brain but liver kidney the
adrenal gland pancreas skin lung heart
etc and and it's really the the fact
that clocks are present everywhere I
think uh leisha blur gets the lion's
share of the credit for really pointing
out doing a seminal experiment to
indicate that this is the case and the
combination of the large number of
cyclers indirectly produced from the
feedback loop plus the many tissues in
which this occurs is the fact gives rise
to the fact that in the entire mammalian
organism more than 50% of all gene
rushon is under circadian control so in
other words in excess of half of the
25,000 genes that we manufacture are
governed by the circadian clock and it's
of course because of that feature that
this picture makes really some sense the
fact that all kinds of phenomena that
were interested in including sleep which
you'll hear about from Mike Young and
metabolism and all sorts of other things
are really under under the control of
the circadian clock so I'm gonna just
say as it was president the introduction
that my current interests are really the
the 75 neurons which function in the fly
brain and within which these red neurons
within which the same circadian feedback
loop occurs in sync and and the question
that we're quite focused on is how do
those neurons give rise to this very
complicated behavioral profile that's
characteristic of Drosophila and many
other insects namely a morning peak of
activity a siesta in the middle of the
day as Jeff indicated these fruit flies
are very smart the the peak of activity
in the evening and that and then sleep
at night and all that whole profile is
really controlled by those 75 neurons
and and I've also become a pseudo neuro
scientists and so we're quite interested
in how to assay firing patterns of
discrete neurons in wake in weight
behaving flies so flies that are running
around and doing all kinds of behavior
how can you really say the firing
patterns of a fly's under those non
constrained conditions and firing
patterns of very discrete subsets of
neurons so I think I think I will turn
in the last couple of minutes to a
couple of
a couple of philosophical points and try
to address this question why am i
receiving this this awesome prize and
what did what did I actually contribute
so that's as Jeff as Jeff told you about
it's the a eyes which really do the work
and a P I who is ever so slightly
introspective asks himself this question
from time to time and especially at
times like this so I am persistent
that's for sure that is a characteristic
of mind
I worked for many years on yeast post
transcriptional regulation and and that
yeast lab of course I didn't have two
labs
I had one lab with two themes and the
people were all intermingled and so
knowing about nucleic acids really
helped our work both experimentally as I
alluded to from the this this rnase
protection experiment of Paul hardens
and also my training the fact is that
circadian rhythms had been dominated by
neuroscience and neuroscientists are
interested in things that happen at the
millisecond level or even sub
millisecond but this didn't make any
sense for phenomena which operates on a
24-hour time scale but the path lives of
RNA pretend proteins does make sense and
and it was with that knowledge that some
of some of this work was done and and
then of course I was smart enough to to
stay out of the way of talented people
and and let them make progress so
there's a lot of luck in good fortune
that goes into it goes into work that
goes into life my attache this week if
you can believe it is named purr
so so III when he introduced himself I
said this I lead a charmed life this
could not possibly really happen to me
that is the nickname of the gene of
course that we worked on so more more
more substantively so I came to Brandeis
AA and I and I encountered genetics I
was not a geneticist before I came to
Brandeis and Jeff was one feature but
only one of several people at Brandeis
who were interested in genetics
recombinant DNA came around just at the
right time for our career this was a
perfect storm I think those of you who
like movies and Jeff Jeff introduced
this this metaphor I could say that
recombinant DNA was our Ingrid Bergman
and to quote from Casablanca
of all the gin joints and all the time
towns and all the worlds she walked into
ours
and and you might not know but the
Epstein brothers who wrote the the
screenplay for Casablanca had two
different endings and on one of them
Rick Blaine gets in the plane to Lisbon
along with Ingrid Bergman and so we had
the we're in Stockholm we had the happy
ending to this story and and so I also
that the feedback loop was correct in
general that was not for sure tons of
cycling RNAs much most of animal
physiology is under control who knew who
knew that's how it would come out I we
were I was fortunate to be funded by
remarkable farsighted organizations HHMI
and I NIH my university is is is a
wonderful meritocracy those those
funding agencies or meritocracies in my
environment was great I have already
mentioned the fact that we it's really
the AIS who do stuff and of course I had
this long friendship and collaboration
with Jeff Hall this allowed us to put
our two labs together as he mentioned
people in his lab like raphson FCE John
you were I got to associate with
co-mentor if you will in the case of
John Patrick Emery in my lab who's not
here collaborated with Ralph on the
cloning of cryptochrome so and then of
course this this had an element a strong
element of personal friendship we we had
we have strong personality differences
Jeff and I I should say and but we
embrace those differences we I think it
was it was really an asset to our work
and certainly enriched me personally
Ralph Greenspan likes likes to say that
we made him think of Gilbert and
Sullivan who are arguably the most
productive collaborating duo in music
and absolutely drove each other
completely crazy in the course of their
collaboration so here's the list of the
people I work with and I want to
particularly mention Ravi
Isaac Patrick Josh Wong Shin pranitha
these are the early day people John root
Allah way ching chang chong cui and
larry zwibell they're they're the people
who contributed to the early days of
this story I had a yeast lab as I
mentioned and and those people have gone
on many of them to fame and fortune and
they were critical to my success one of
those East people became my wife no job
of itch and and of course there's Naja
and I with our two daughters and so as
as some friends of mine like to say not
only would I not be standing here
without them but I would be dead and and
and and lastly let me just say and with
family and Naja as a segue that that
science my view of science is a very
romantic profession
but you're going to discover every day
as an adventure and and it's it's really
a great privilege enjoy a romance as I
said and I think I'll end on that note
with a short poem which is present in
Ralph Greenspan's book fly pushing and
it's written by his wife Danny and
here's the poem Oh Gino type of
phenotype this kiss had better last her
he's off to see his other love
Drosophila melanogaster thank you very
much
[Applause]
[Music]
and so now we've come to what maybe we
can call our third period in this
afternoon
Michael W young is a professor at
Rockefeller University he is a biologist
and a geneticist he earned his
undergraduate degree as we heard in
biology from the University of Texas at
Austin in 1971 after a summer of
research with Burke Judd and probably
this emphasizes the importance of summer
internships he was working with a
Drosophila genome and that probably
spurred on his interest in science
because he remained at the University of
Texas to complete a PhD in genetics in
1975 Michael Young continued his studies
throughout his postdoctoral training at
Stanford University School of Medicine
with an interest in molecular genetics
where he worked in Dave Hogg mrs. lab
from 1978 he's been on the faculty of
Rockefeller University in New York in
2004 Mike young was appointed vice
president for academic affairs at
Rockefeller University and he was also
granted the Richard and gene Fisher
chair Michael Young is a member of the
US National Academy of Sciences and his
research has shown how interactions
among certain genes and their proteins
produce molecular oscillations at the
level of individual cells I would like
to ask all of you in joining me to
welcome Mike Young up to the podium to
deliver his Nobel lecture entitled time
travels a 40 year journey from Joseph
Allis clock mutants to human circadian
disorders
[Applause]
ah bright lights it's wonderful to be
here so I guess I
I'm the caboose I'll pull us along and
fill in a few gaps and tell you about
some more recent work that's been on
this me let me start by just Jeff had
talked about rhythms being all around us
and I think this is an example my wife
were out on and I were out on a hike a
few summers ago in New Mexico and we
came across this whoops
came across this plant which is called
the Colorado four o'clock and what I
want you to notice is that all the
blooms are closed and notice this this
little branch here I'm not I'm playing
straight this is it two o'clock when
we're going out on the hike two hours
later a few hours later we come back and
we see this at 6 p.m. so this remarkable
plant rhythm is believed to be due to
the behavior of the pollinator hawkmoth
which is active at night in the evenings
and of course you're in a desert
environment that's arid water is
precious and it takes water pumped into
the petals of those leaves to open them
up so this appears to be a strategy it
seems to conserve water in an arid
environment and have those blooms
available for pollination at times that
makes sense with regard to the behavior
of your pollinator another example of
these rhythms that are all around us is
this record of hamster behavior that
appeared in a symposium volume in 1960
this is each each line is a is a 24-hour
interval so you're looking at 25 days in
this animals life in
complete darkness the whole time and it
still amazes me when the animal gets on
its running wheel you get these
deflections from that line and you can
you can predict within a couple of
minutes each day when the animals going
to get on the running wheel and when
it's going to get off and you'll notice
another feature this is it's not 24
hours it's about 24 hours it's circadian
which you know how could it be anything
other than an internal reflection of
some kind of an internal pacemaker as
Michael pointed out we have still other
phenotypes as we acquire new tools to
look more deeply for red Missa tee
these are rhythms that are established
in the head of the fruit fly this was of
Drosophila this was work of Adam Clara
Chang and Herman V Ninh about 15 16
years ago using microarray data and the
way you read this is that this is 150
gene pattern stacked one on top of the
other each row of red and green boxes is
the pattern of a single gene followed
over six 24-hour intervals some with a
light dark cycle but others in complete
darkness and they're stacked according
to time of day of their maximum
expression so so the maximally at dawn
at noon these at dusk these at midnight
and so forth and I think what I hope you
see are red and green stripes running
top to bottom just illustrating these
waves of expression over this very large
group of genes and the other thing I'd
like to point out is that those are not
vertical stripes they're they're running
diagonally across the chart which is
pointing out for us that this timer is
not simply swinging back and forth
between two states day and night
it's a program that generates patterns
of gene expression where every hour of
the day there's a unique relationship
between genes that are hitting their
peaks and genes that are hitting their
lows the next slide shows that same
pattern but now next to it
our results that are obtained with three
clock mutants period timeless and clock
so those are no mutants and where are
the stripes the stripes are now gone and
as Michael pointed out in his talk a few
minutes ago what we appreciate is that
not only does the behavior go away with
these mutants but all of the genetic
changes that are programmed these this
temporal program is eliminated by loss
of those genes and this is unique to the
genes that contribute to this pacemaker
mechanism that we've been studying so
just to give you an overview once again
of the way this pacemaker works we have
the period and timeless genes on
different chromosomes in the nucleus
transcripts are produced by Association
of clock and cycle activating
transcription of both per and timeless
their RNAs are translated in the
cytoplasm to give timeless and period
proteins but then we run into some post
transcriptional breaks on the system
that produced the oscillations that we
see one of the important initial breaks
is produced by a gene we called double
time that's turned out when cloned in
sequence to be casein kinase 1 and that
kinase phosphorylates the period protein
and marks it for destruction so at the
early stage of each daily cycle when
period proteins and timeless proteins
are at very low levels double time which
is constitutively produced at high
levels at all times of day and night is
the first partner that the period
protein sees and so most of the early
period proteins that are produced
are immediately dispensed with in the
cell on the other on the other hand many
hours later as timeless proteins build
up as we have higher and higher levels
of timeless proteins we now can produce
something new which is a period timeless
dimer and period timeless dimers are
immune to this phosphorylation based
destruction by double time and they also
have a property that they now seek the
nucleus whereas period and timeless on
their own seek the cytoplasm and of
course as you've already heard period
and timeless are inhibitors they bind to
physically clock and cycle and repress
the action of those activators to close
the cycle in a light dark cycle that
would all happen in constant darkness
which is why we see oscillations
principally in constant darkness but in
day/night cycles we also have the issue
of the these clocks following the phase
of the environmental cycle and that's
achieved in the fly by a protein called
cryptochrome which is a fotolia's like
molecule that absorbs light when it
absorbs light it physically associates
with timeless recruits proteins that
will cause both timeless and
cryptochrome to become phosphorylated
and degraded so that all day long when
the Sun is up
we have no timeless because of the
activation of cryptochrome and of course
if you have no timeless all the period
protein will only have one partner which
is double time which means we also have
no period so we have massive amounts of
RNA for both period and timeless during
the day time but it's sterile in the
sense that we're not accumulating
protein until the Sun Goes Down and this
is essentially how the phase of the of
this clock is established and as we move
a fly from New York to Stockholm for
example you can see the effects that
would be expected from this kind of a
mechanism
the as as Michael pointed out there's a
great deal of homology when we move from
the fly to other animals the rest of the
animal kingdom so in US for example we
have many familiar proteins we have a
clock and beam-out which are the
orthologs of clock and cycle in the fly
we have three period proteins / 1 / 2 +
/ 3 all of which are related to the
single period protein that we have in
the fly we also once again have casein
kinase 1 the double time ortholog in
mammals which once again controls the
accumulation and fate of the period
protein one difference an important
difference we have is whereas
cryptochrome was a partner for timeless
controlling its accumulation now
cryptochrome has become the partner for
/ which is a an interesting evolutionary
switch in dance partners but it's it's a
cryptochrome / dimer instead of a
timeless / dimer that now moves to
nuclei and inhibits the action of clock
and bmail and I'll come back to these
differences in a few moments when I
begin to speak more about human clocks
so originally the discovery that clocks
were found all over the body was a
discovery in flies it was made in
drosophila by Jeff Hall in collaboration
with Steve Kay in 1997 and they had
generated a form of / which was
connected to lucifer raised so that you
could use a light monitoring scheme to
to image live Drosophila and all that
the the intact and and dissected body
parts of the fly and realized that there
were / driven cycles all over all over
the fly and as Michael pointed out we
now know that much the same
is true for mammals including ourselves
and in this example I'm just giving you
examples of clocks that are found in the
brain versus the lung the liver and
skeletal muscle and I want to suggest
some of the things that might happen to
you if you move from New York to
Stockholm or even when you impose a
brain body conflict experimentally in
the lab that can be studied continuously
for many many days so if if this mouse
is kept on New York City time it's a
nocturnal animal it's going to be active
at night it's going to be sleeping
during the day if unperturbed it will
want to eat at night when it's active
and be quiescent during the day and we
we have these clocks in different
tissues all agreeing on the time zone
they're all agreeing that they're
working together on New York City time
many years ago Michael menaker at the
University of Virginia did an experiment
in which he established a brain body
conflict by allowing the mouse to eat
only in the middle of the day when it
should be in the middle of its sleep
interval provide food for an hour or so
after a few days the animal learns to
predict will wake up spontaneously
before the food is delivered eat the
food go back to sleep but then get on
its running wheel and run on the wheel
all night as it would appropriately for
New York City what was found after a few
days of this though is that the clocks
everywhere except the brain had changed
their phases by this new routine so the
the brain is still stuck in New York
it's seeing that light-dark cycle it's
producing those activity rhythms that
are appropriate at night but the rest of
the body
in disagreement is not pulled along by
what the brain thinks is going on
they're getting their cues directly from
the feeding schedule or from other
organs organs in the animal that are
responding directly from the feeding
schedule so we have in effect an animal
that who's a collection of clocks that
can't agree with one another and this is
remarkably similar to what happens when
we undergo jetlag different organs
proceed to the new time zone at
different paces we're very much this is
very much a problem of a multiplicity of
clocks that can't agree for several days
when we change time zones dramatically
in this fashion what we do know from
these kinds of experiments is if the
animal is maintained for many days or
even weeks we begin to see a number of
anomalous events in metabolism and
behavior that are consistent with much
more severe effects that come from
actually eliminating clocks in these
different subsets of organs so let me
turn these that we've been doing in
humans that consider a related problem
which is what if your clock doesn't
agree with the environmental cycle we've
got a 24-hour environmental cycle what
if you're genetically programmed to have
a clock as we've heard in flies like a
first short or a purl on what happens if
we have a clock that's out of sync with
the with the turning of the earth and
I'm going to be talking about a syndrome
called delayed sleep phase disorder we
can think of individuals that have this
disorder as night owls extreme night
owls so they might be hammering away on
their keyboards late at night getting a
big burst of energy off of their
computer screen which is if anything
going to make things worse for them late
into the night
and these are some of the attributes of
these individuals we think this this
appears to affect about 5% of the
population from clinical studies it's a
persistent delay in the timing of the
major sleep episode and strong
resistance to efforts to try to
manipulate sleep phase to advance it to
make it easier to show up for work at
eight or nine o'clock in the morning for
example
so these are records from two
individuals that were in a study we
began a number of years ago on the left
is a control subject which we'll call
tau 18 and these are activity records
wait sleep records then involve two
kinds of monitoring one is with a like
activity monitor and the other is just
with entries in a sleep log that's kept
by the bed so that each day or evening
when the end of a individual gets into
bed they marked the time down and when
they get out of bed they put another
mark in the log so we have two
correlated pieces of data to consider so
the way the data are plotted here is to
plot not just 24 hours but 48 hour
intervals in this process and what this
allows us to do is compare the time that
each end that the individual is getting
into bed with the time that the
individual is getting out of bed so you
notice in the control subject from both
the sleep log and the activity graphs
that there's a very neat and consistent
pattern in which about 11:30 to midnight
this individual is getting in bed each
night and rapidly thereafter going to
sleep and at 7 or 8 each morning again
pretty consistently they become active
and they put a mark in the sleep log
that they're getting out of bed
the dspd subjects tau 11 has a quite an
erratic record by comparison but I think
the most important features are if we
look at the in bed times versus the out
of bed times we see that this is an
individual that's always getting in bed
well after midnight
and the out of bed times they're getting
there they're there they're becoming
active again usually just a little bit
before noon so this is a striking phase
variation with regard to the timing
event of their awake sleep cycle
we were able to study that individual
and several members of the family and
did a a whole exome sequencing of all of
these members of the extended family and
we found that there were a number of
those indicated in black or gray that
had an aberrant pattern of sleep and one
cousin over here with a normal sleep
pattern and the difference that came up
by whole exome sequencing in these
individuals gave us one most likely
candidate which is a variation at the
gene cryptochrome one this mutation is a
single nucleotide change it's at a
splice donor site just downstream from
exon 11 and that change predicts that
exon 12 will be spliced now directly tax
sign exon 10 skipping of the information
in exon 11 so that would predict a 70 to
base base is missing in the messenger
RNA and 24 amino acids missing from the
protein and here are we had collected
dermal fibroblasts from each of the
subjects in this study there were 20 or
so subjects that we studied and you'll
see subject 11 is uniquely producing two
forms of the RNA from cryptochrome one
and two forms of protein in the skin in
the in the dermal fibroblasts so clearly
a significant change in the structure of
both the RNA in the protein in this
individual we went on to ask whether or
not that modified gene was enough to
change the circadian clock of a naive
cultured cell and Alena Pat Kay in our
lab did this by starting with the
cultured cell that had no copy of
cryptochrome usually would have two
copies cryptochrome one
cryptochrome - if you have no copies
you'll have you'll be a rhythmic the
cells will be a rhythmic and she used
this as a test system to ask is there a
difference in the pattern of circadian
rhythmicity at the cellular level given
a wild-type form of cryptochrome one or
this variant form of cryptochrome one
and as you see here there was a very
consistent pattern of rhythmicity that
comes from the wild-type form the
full-length form of cryptochrome and
this truncated form gave a pattern with
a longer circadian rhythm about half an
hour longer than that provided by the
wild-type gene so clearly this gene is
capable of producing a change in the
circadian rhythm of that of the
recipient cells so once again the
difference between the fly clock over
here and the human clock shown in the
right important new role for
cryptochrome so this is the this of
course is the gene that is now modified
in this case cryptochrome the work it
does is in conjunction with purr to form
that inhibitory complex that suppresses
the activity of clock in cycles so
keeping that in mind Elina went took a
look at the interactions among these
proteins we know from that model from
what's known about the human clock and
the fly clock that period and
cryptochrome will be partners to form an
inhibitory complex that will then
further physically interact with clock
and be male and so she asked the
following question does it matter with
regard to the physical Association among
these proteins whether you're the
full-length form of this protein of the
truncated form of the protein so if I
start down here for example and we have
input proteins where we've created only
the full-length protein is provided or
the truncated form of the protein is
provided or a synthetic heterozygote in
which both forms of the protein are
produced
what happens if you now do an immunity
rotational glutenous associated clock
and what is found is that the
full-length form of cryptochrome is very
weakly recovered much stronger recovery
of the truncated form and in this
synthetic heterozygote again a strong
bias toward the truncated form of the
protein up here on the left is just a
reciprocal experiment where you're the
focus of immune of precipitation is B
mal and again the inputs are over here
and we see much the same response the
full-length protein is recovered poorly
relative to the robust recovery of the
truncated protein and the synthetic
heterozygote is strongly biased toward
the truncated form of the protein in
contrast if we look at what's happening
with interactions with purr itself
how does cryptochrome the how did these
two varieties of cryptochrome interact
with purr itself we find here's the
input that the input and they pulled
down same so in summary what is seems to
be the case is that period in
cryptochrome appeared to have a strong
physical interaction that is not
affected by this mutation but the
interaction of the period cryptochrome
heterodimer with its target activator
proteins o'clock and b mal is strongly
altered by this mutation so we thought
all of this was extremely interesting at
the level of molecular biology but we
were really stunned when we sat down at
a computer a few years ago and asked
well how common is this mutation in
human populations and this is a this is
what we we saw when we did that looking
at the exact database available through
Cambridge the overall world population
the the frequency of this allele suggest
that carriers and
again this is behaving as a dominant so
far as as we've seen so far carriers
would be almost 1% level in the
population if we focus on Europeans
those that are European or European
descent the allele frequency is shown
here so twice that would be the carrier
frequency that's about one in 75 both of
European descent so we were stunned that
this allele which had these features
changing the function of the clock was
so prevalent but it did suggest that we
should be able to identify without a lot
of trouble additional carriers to
confirm this relationship and we set up
a collaboration with typhoon o selec at
Bilkent University in in Turkey who had
been working with a colleague across the
hall
Jeff Friedman and typhoon recognized a
number of families that had carriers
both homozygous and heterozygous
carriers large families only a few of
which are shown here and by looking at
the patterns of sleep in all of these
individuals were able to to compare the
patterns shown in the filled boxes the
dark boxes carrier boxes versus those in
the unfilled boxes which are non
carriers and we can plot the behaviors
of these two groups as shown here the
non carriers the the shown over here
that have what we call a mid sleep
measurement on free days so on three
days when do you go to sleep when do you
wake up and what's the midpoint of that
interval and for most of us that's going
to be around 4:30 in the morning and
that's true for most of the non carriers
in these families but their relatives
who are carriers whether heterozygous or
homozygous have a very different pattern
that's shifted by
about two hours very much like the
original probe and that we studied where
the mid sleep point is about the time
that most of us would be getting up and
taking off for work the there's a second
phenotype that emerged which are
fragmented sleepers these are
individuals that that that point to
their major sleep episode is a short nap
that can be early or late in the evening
again something not seen in the
non-carriers so to summarize what we've
seen we've got a number of unrelated
families in which the presence of this
variation predicts the SPD the high
frequency the penetrants the high
penetrance of this mutation with regard
to that behavior suggest a significant
contribution to dspd worldwide since the
mutation is found in multiple members of
each family it's running through the
families it's being inherited we have to
assume that every tissue has these
altered clocks the the variation shows
enhanced binding to clock and B mail as
I pointed out and it appears to be a
strengthened transcriptional inhibitor
by other work that I don't have time to
talk about today the competitive binding
to clock and B mail suggests a molecular
basis for the dominance of this trait
and finally as I mentioned it's
sufficient to express just this one gene
in individual cells in culture and
recapitulate an altered circadian rhythm
so lastly I just like to point at some
questions we have for the future one of
the problems in studying sleep disorders
there's been relationships to other
medical conditions it's long been the
case that anecdotally a variety and
psychiatric disorders are often said to
be associated with disordered sleep
and very often the laid sleep and but
it's been difficult or impossible to
establish causal relationships but what
we have here I believe is a new
opportunity if you have large numbers of
subjects that are available to study we
should be able to test whether a
particular sleep mutation extends to
other medical problems and particularly
when the mutation can be studied as it's
traveling through unrelated families we
should be able to rule out the impact of
environment and and make some clear
conclusions about the relationship of
mutations of this sort to other medical
disorders and lastly let me just point
to the work to the people the AI says
Jeff put it in the lab that have
contributed to this work over the many
years in the 1980s
Ted bar jello and Rob Jackson were
involved in the initial mapping and
cloning of the period gene sequencing
identifying the nature of the mutations
that Ron Konopka and Seymour Benzer had
initially found some years before in the
1990s Leslie
amita Jeff lino and Adrian all worked on
the discovery and characterization of
the timeless gene and it's protein
shortly thereafter jeff preiss lino
adrian justin and brian all worked on
the discovery and characterization of
double time whose role I told you about
and in the 2000s we began to move into
the era of micro arrays and looking at
the larger patterns of gene expression
that are controlled by these clocks and
that was principally driven by Adam
Clara Chang and Hermann V Ninh but still
more genes to be discovered Sebastian
Martinek found a role for GS k3 which is
particularly interested
staying still because of its sensitivity
to common commonly used drug treatments
such as lithium in the 2010 or the last
seven years drug and arugula and Nick
stavropoulos have both initiated studies
of a different kind of genetics that of
the control of sleep duration the
homeostatic control of sleep which along
with circadian regulation controls the
ultimately controls the pattern and as I
mentioned Elena Potkin has been involved
in every aspect of our our human work
and I'll just show one last slide I want
to point first to lino saez who was a
member of the laboratory for almost 30
years he was involved in almost
everything that I spoke about today I li
know unfortunately passed away in 2014
but I know he would really love to have
been able to be here Elena Pat key again
has been responsible for every aspect of
the human work she's had her hands on
every part of that project and she is
here and I just want to thank her
personally so thanks for your attention
and after the iron
I would like to extend our gratitude to
the Nobel laureates sieve presentations
this afternoon may I ask the laureates
on to the stage for a round of applause
[Applause]